- It's good to be back.
♫ We're unstoppable
- Back in action.
We're supposed to play
basketball at 5:30 this morning.
Gym was closed.
I would've been at the gym.
Tyler, you should kiss AJ in the face.
You were already up
here, weren't you, DRock?
- I was back here.
- Really good month.
Got a ton of family time.
Hey, Wine Library, it's
Gary Vaynerchuk, former host
of Wine Library TV, and Sasha Vaynerchuk.
Took a little trip to Boston.
Yo, I'm about to go give
this talk, but real quick,
if you want to join the
Wine Club, swipe up.
Quick little keynote in Germany.
Just gave a great talk,
felt really good about it.
Little bit more of serious demeanor.
Real fun.
Got to take my sister Liz on that trip.
- [Man] We can't show her,
this is Gary's sister.
- Caught up is Ryssa.
Who's tryna disappear.
Ryssa, don't be scared.
There she is.
Has been with Vayner for
the last five or six years.
Ryssa, six years?
All right, she's gone.
Now, I'm gettin' a quick haircut.
(popping)
Now, that I got my haircut,
now, now I'm rejuvenated.
I think one of the things
that has separated me
in the business world my
entire 20-year career,
sorry, Brandon, I'm kinda
talkin' to YouTube right now,
so stick with me, but
this is for you, too.
It's just fuckin' about
the things that matter.
Everybody has 40 hours, 80
hours in a week, depending
on how you roll.
That's why I'm so obsessed
with new customers.
That's why I'm so obsessed with 900.
Every time I step away from
a situation, whether at Wine
Library, Team Gary, at Vayner
Media, one of the things
that always spike to the top
of the list, prioritizing
things that matter.
Things that impact your business.
Buying and selling and customer
service is what impacts
Wine Library, not just
following the process.
Everybody's so (bleeping) oriented.
Everybody's religious to the process.
Do the things that matter.
Do the things that drive impact.
Do the things that actually
will change your business.
Patience is equally tied
in to things that matter
a lot of times, because the
things that matter are hard,
so it takes time.
That's why I have time to
sit down with my employees.
I think those are the
things that actually matter.
Hey.
- Hey, what's up, man?
- Hey man, sorry.
- Do you have a minute, I
could give you a gift that's
something that I got from
the 2017 flip challenge?
- Yes.
- Listen, I wonder if
you have a just a second
for a New Jersey hustler.
- Real fast, like 30 seconds.
- [Man] One minute,
thirty-seven seconds later.
- Love it, man.
Take care of yourself.
- Peace and love.
- [Gary] Stay well.
- I'll see you at the super tasting.
- I'll see you there.
Do anything interesting?
- I started playing Pickleball.
- You did?
- What is Pickleball.
(ball whacking)
(yelling)
- God, people are really all about that.
(popping)
Where are you putting out content now?
Instagram?
- Facebook and YouTube.
- Instagram, Facebook.
- So, it was really fun.
YouTube, I'm really
tryna go deeper for you
in this new iteration.
I realized, ah, document
over create was such
a breakthrough for so many of
you, but there is a middle.
Besides interviewing somebody,
Q and A is the easiest way
to create content, instead
of creating it yourself.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- You know the whole
document versus create?
Well, maybe you guys don't
wanna be reality TV stars
and document your whole day.
Just 'cause documenting
versus creating works
for so many of you.
My whole thing is just start.
And what holds everybody back is creation.
- [Woman] Mm.
- Which is why documenting
over create because such
a big thing.
And I think the thing that
make you is a Q and A format.
It's not on you.
But, you need to just pick
phone numbers, and be like,
"Hey, Karen, from Kansas
City, what's your question?"
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Guys, I hope it was a good experience.
This is the year to wear one Vaynerchuk.
Thanks, man, thank you, so much.
Continued success.
- Thank you guys.
- Hit me up anytime.
Q and A is a huge way to go.
An absolute breakthrough
that we're gonna expand on.
- Big fan!
Just started following you.
- Thank you, brother.
What's up, fellas?
- What's up.
(beeping)
- Hey.
- I'm Marcus.
- How you doin', Marcus?
- I'm gonna be
your photographer, man, let's do it.
- Gary, how's it going?
Michael.
- Michael, such a pleasure.
Hi.
- Hi.
Marissa.
- Marissa, such a pleasure.
Cool.
- Don't have to worry about
changing these at all.
- Okay.
- So, we'll get you in those.
And then, we're doing just a couple
shirt changes throughout, kay?
- Yep.
So, I'm gonna take some
photos here, video for this
Shopify thing that I'm
doing with my (bleeping).
Super excited about it.
I'm not even sure I'm allowed
to talk about it, now.
Beep where I said what it
is, but excited about it.
Trying to get my modeling game up.
(popping)
So, back to Vayner?
- [Man] Yep.
- Back to Vayner.
Super excited about this
contest I'm a part of.
Got a quick phone call right now.
I'm probably two minutes late.
Two minutes late?
- Yeah, you'll be four.
- Four.
Gotta go.
Puttin' all the pieces together.
My boy Russ.
Fuckin' fired up.
I fuckin' love his music.
You, Me is probably...
Hey, Alexa, can you play You, Me by Russ?
Hey, Alexa?
What's the matter with my Alexa?
- [Alexa] I can't find You, Me by Russ.
- [Man] It'll be on YouTube.
- What the (bleeping), Alexa?
(chattering)
- We're on a good street here,
but there was a bad street
that went here.
Until next time, thank you so much.
- But you're gonna be,
this is like an official,
but kind of like, but you're still like
gonna be here, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay, we'll see you later.
It's important.
I'm gonna be there anyway.
I might as well get some show time.
So, what is this, bro?
Oh, this is not the juice prep.
What is this?
- That's a protein shake.
- [Man] Hold on.
- [Gary] Dude, that was such
a big loss, I'm stunned.
That's a lot.
- I told you that was gonna happen, too.
- [Man] What happened, you lost?
- [Gary] I've gained so much weight.
But then last night, in
one day of fasting, I lost
the most weight I've ever--
- Five pounds.
- Yeah.
- How is that?
Is that all right?
- Yeah.
- Good.
- It's fucking great.
- Okay, good.
(upbeat music)
- We're at a client event.
Fun to see the team and
clients get together.
A lot of times, we can't
show you guys a lot
of client stuff.
I think it's a real indication
of a lot of the stuff
you guys haven't been able
to see behind the scenes.
I'm always laughing,
we're always laughing,
because so much of my
day is Vayner Media, yet,
because so much of that is
confidential, I can't show
you guys the day in, day out
grind of client services,
building an organization,
having 800 employees,
having 50 clients, a
$100,000,000 plus media company.
A lot of shit.
But I'm glad we get to
show you that today,
especially kinda being on
the bounce back episode.
I always tell you guys
watch what I'm doing,
not what I'm saying.
If I'm posting a lot
on Instagram, matters.
If I'm focused on my podcast, matters.
If I'm DMing at scale, matters.
This is a nice way to
narrate what I've been trying
to get you to do all along,
which is watch me and why.
- [Man] I might get fucked.
- Why, what happened?